Добрий день.
Починаємо урок математики, 5 клас.
Проведу його я, Олена Бурдун.
Тема нашого уроку: «Знаходження числа
за його десятковим дробом».
Спочатку згадаємо задачу, яку я вам
задала наприкінці минулого уроку.
Нагадаю, що замість зірочок
треба поставити такі цифри,
щоб ділення було виконано вірно.
Давайте подивимось.
Ми з вами ділимо в цілій частині
одноцифрове число на двоцифрове число.
Звичайно в результаті буде 0.
Тепер ми повинні 39 помножити
на якусь цифру
і отримати двоцифрове
число, перша цифра якого 7
39 будемо множити на 2
і отримаємо число 78.
Що далі будемо робити?
39 треба помножити на якусь цифру,
щоб в кінці отримати 5.
Будемо 39 множити на 5.
Отримаємо 195,
значить 195 віднімали від 195,
тому що в результаті отримали 0.
Тоді остаточний результат 9,75 поділити
на 39 отримаємо 0,25.
Ось так ви повинні були
розв’язати це завдання.
Переходимо до вивчення нової теми.
Розв’яжемо наступну задачу.
Учні 5-А класу з’їли 30 ватрушок,
що становить 0,15 від того,
що випекли у шкільній їдальні.
Скільки ватрушок випекли в їдальні?
Запишемо короткий запис умови.
Випекли – невідомо штук ватрушок (?).
Всю кількість ватрушок ми приймемо за 1,
а з’їли 30 штук
і це становить 0,15 від всієї
кількості ватрушок.
Спочатку знайдемо одну соту.
Для цього 30 поділимо на 15,
отримаємо 2 штуки.
Нагадаю, що дріб 0,15 вказує,
що ціла кількість ватрушок
була поділена на 100 рівних частин
і взяли тільки 15 частин.
Ось ці 15 частин і складають 30 ватрушок.
Тому, щоб знайти одну соту частину
ми 30 поділили на 15.
А тепер знайдемо одне ціле.
2 ватрушки, це одна сота частина.
Щоб знайти всі 100 частин,
треба 2 помножити на 100,
це буде 200 штук ватрушок,
це ціла одиниця.
Саме стільки ватрушок
випекли у шкільній їдальні.
Цей розв’язок можна записати
у вигляді виразу 30:15х100
і виявляється, що це буде те саме,
що 30:0,15.
Відповідь отримаємо ту саму –
200 штук ватрушок.
Таким чином, щоб знайти число
за його десятковим дробом,
можна дане число поділити на
відповідний йому десятковий дріб.
Перейдемо до розв’язання задачі.
Планував виконати все завдання –
- невідома кількість хвилин (?).
Виконав завдання з української мови
за 24 хвилини
і це складає 0,8
від всього завдання,
яке ми позначимо за 1.
Для того, щоб розв’язати цю задачу
необхідно 24:0,8.
Для того, щоб поділити число
на десятковий дріб
треба друге число
перетворити на натуральне.
Переносимо кому в даному випадку
на одну цифру праворуч
і отримаємо 240:8=30 хвилин.
Відповідь: планував виконати завдання
за 30 хвилин.
Наступна задача.
Запишемо короткий запис умови.
Весь шлях – невідомо (?)
кілометрів і це 1.
Проїхав також невідому (?)
кількість кілометрів,
але ми знаємо, що це становить 0,6 частин
від всього шляху.
Залишилось проїхати 6 кілометрів.
Нам треба знайти весь шлях.
Скажіть, будь ласка, чи знаємо ми
скільки йому лишилося проїхати в частинах?
Ні не знаємо, але ми це можемо дізнатися.
Весь шлях – одиниця,
то ми від 1 віднімемо ту частину,
яку велосипедист проїхав спочатку 0,6.
Отримаємо 0,4 - це скільки
залишилось проїхати.
Значить ми в умові можемо дописати,
що 6 кілометрів складає
0,4 від всього шляху.
Тепер ми зможемо знайти весь шлях.
Для цього 6 поділимо на 0,4.
Переносимо коми,
60 поділити на 4 це буде 15 кілометрів.
Відповідь: весь шлях – 15 кілометрів.
Наступна задача.
Площа (S) дорівнює 64,8 квадратних метрів.
Одна сторона (а) дорівнює 12 метрів.
Нам треба знайти периметр (Р)
прямокутної ділянки (?).
Для знаходження периметра прямокутника
нам треба знати ширину і довжину.
Ми знаємо одну сторону – 12 метрів.
Для того, щоб знайти другу сторону
ми попрацюємо з формулою
площі прямокутника.
Площу (S) прямокутника можна знайти,
якщо перемножити сторони (а*в).
Якщо нам відома одна сторона,
то другу сторону ми можемо знайти
коли 64,8 поділимо на 12.
Виконаємо ділення у стовпчик.
64:12, візьмемо по 5.
12х5 буде 60,
різниця 4.
Знесли 8 з дробової частини,
значить в результаті поставили кому.
48:12, візьмемо по 4.
Отже, друга сторона дорівнює 5,4 метри.
Тепер знайдемо периметр (Р).
Нагадаю вам формулу периметра.
Периметр можна обрахувати,
якщо помножити суму сторін на 2.
2 помножимо на суму чисел 12 та 5,4.
12+5,4=17,4
помножимо на 2 і отримаємо 34,8 метри.
Це наш периметр (Р.)
Відповідь: Р =34,8 метри.
Перейдемо до усного рахунку.
Знайдіть закономірність і запишіть
наступні два числа в цьому ряду
0,2; 0,4; 1,2; 4,8;
Здогадалися?
Давайте будемо розв’язувати разом.
Зверніть увагу, для того
щоб отримати друге число
ми перше число помножили на 2.
Для того щоб отримати третє число
ми попереднє число (друге) помножили на 3.
Щоб отримати четверте число
ми попереднє число помножили на 4.
Значить, щоб отримати наступне число
ми попереднє повинні помножити на 5,
а потім помножити на 6.
Переходимо до розв’язання рівнянь.
Запишемо перше рівняння.
2,6х+5,04=5,3.
Спочатку знайдемо невідомий доданок 2,6х.
Для цього від суми
віднімемо відомий доданок.
Хто може рахувати усно, рахує усно.
Хто ще не опанував усний рахунок
для вас виконаємо віднімання у стовпчик.
При відніманні десяткові дроби
підписуємо таким чином,
щоб кома опинилась під комою.
Якщо у нас не вистачає
в дробовій частині цифр,
то в кінці дробової частини
можна поставити 0.
Переходимо до віднімання.
Від 10 відняти 4 це буде 6.
Зайняли одну розрядну одиницю,
тепер замість 3 десятих
у нас стоїть 2 десятих
і 5 мінус 5 буде 0.
Кому ставимо під комою.
Отримали 0,26.
Тепер, щоб знайти х
ми добуток ділимо на відомий множник.
Давайте спробуємо виконати це ділення
наступним чином.
Ми повинні 0,26 поділити на 2,6
для цього друге число ми перетворимо
в натуральне число,
переносимо коми на одну цифру праворуч.
Будемо ділити 2,6 на 26.
Спробуємо усно 2:26, 0 цілих.
Тепер 26 поділимо на 26.
Отримали 0,1.
Отже, х=0,1.
Запишемо друге рівняння.
1,2n+1,3n-1,39 = 0,61
Спочатку спростимо ліву частину.
До двох перших доданків застосуємо
розподільну властивість
множення відносно додавання.
Отримаємо (1,2+1,3)
і помножити на n
та відняти 1,39
дорівнює 0,61.
Додавання виконаємо усно.
Буде 2,5n-1,39
і в правій частині запишемо 0,61.
Знайдемо 2,5n,
для цього до різниці 0,61
додамо від’ємник 1,39.
2,5n дорівнює.
Це додавання можна виконати усно
61+39=100,
але 1 ми повинні перенести в цілу частину
і в результаті буде 2.
Тепер знайдемо невідомий множник.
Для цього 2 поділимо на 2,5.
Дільник треба перетворити
на натуральне число,
тобто 20 будемо ділити на 25.
20:25, 0 цілих.
Допишемо нуль до 20.
200:25 візьмемо по 8.
В результаті отримаємо, що n=0,8.
І останнє рівняння.
Сума числа 51,32 та х
помножена на 0,12
і це все дорівнює 72.
Спочатку знайдемо дужку,
невідомий множник,
для цього добуток
поділимо на відомий множник.
72 поділити на 0,12
кому треба перенести на 2 знаки вправо.
7200:12.
Візьмемо по 6
у результат допишемо два нулі
і отримаємо 600.
Тепер знайдемо невідомий х.
Для цього від 600 треба відняти 51,32.
Давайте віднімемо у стовпчик,
повторимо віднімання десяткових дробів.
600 цілих кома стоїть
після останнього нуля,
після другого нуля.
Для того, щоб у нас з’явилась
дробова частина
необхідно в десяткову частину дробову
дописати два нулі.
З 6 займемо один розряд
і розпишемо його наступним чином.
10-2=8; 9-3=6;
9-1=8; 9-5=4
і у 6 займали один розряд,
значить там лишилось 5.
Х=548,68
Зараз я на дошці
буду швидко писати приклади,
а ви швидко усно рахуйте
і у зошит записуйте тільки відповіді.
Потім перевіримо ваш результат.
Ну що, перевіряємо?
Коли ми множимо на 100,
то ми кому переносимо на 2 знаки вправо,
наше число збільшується і ми отримали 51.
Коли ми множимо на 0,1 число зменшується.
Кому переносимо вліво на один знак,
бо після коми в цьому числі стоїть
тільки одна цифра.
Ми отримаємо 0,051.
Коли ділимо на 10 число також зменшується
і кома переноситься ліворуч на один знак.
Буде 0,051.
А коли ділимо на маленьке число,
то число збільшується
кома переноситься
на стільки знаків вправо,
скільки знаків стоїть у другому числі
після коми.
В даному випадку на два знаки
і ми отримаємо 51.
Переходимо до закінчення уроку.
Додому задам вам додаткове завдання.
На наступному уроці
перевіримо ваш результат.
Підсумуємо.
На уроці ми навчилися
знаходити число за його десятковим дробом
та повторили дії з десятковими дробами.
Лунає дзвоник.
До зустрічі.